[Applauso]
[Musica]
tutto è visibile istantaneamente
attraverso questo male siamo proprio
sicuri
indossiamo degli occhiali attraverso i
quali osserviamo il mondo
le lenti di questi occhiali sono fatte
dalle opinioni che condividiamo con il
nostro gruppo di appartenenza dalle
ideologie che sposiamo dai pregiudizi
che ereditiamo dai condizionamenti
psicologici che subiamo attraverso
le lenti guardiamo il mondo e anche le
immagini che condividiamo
istantaneamente sono filtrate da queste
lenti e non mi riferisco agli obiettivi
delle telecamere
questi occhiali però si possono togliere
e quando togliamo gli occhiali
osserviamo la realtà ossia mettiamo tra
parentesi i pregiudizi i giudizi che ci
precedono e che limitano la nostra
libera capacità di visione come regista
di film documentari quando esplora una
realtà mi levo gli occhiali in braccio
la mia telecamera e vado a vedere come
stanno le cose di persona in questo
processo realtà all'occhio che esplora
il mondo non fa finta di non esserci ma
si mette in gioco e questa è la sua
forza non il suo limite mi cadono nella
realtà sconosciuta la esploro
trascorrendo del tempo da straniera e
osservo come regista di film documentari
ma anche come docente di linguaggio
audiovisivo o un metodo per ricostruire
visioni e trasmettere
mi piace però usare la parola contagio
pensiamo non alla malattia ma la risata
esistono risate che sono contagiose
ecco a me piace ricostruire visioni che
siano contagiose come una risata qualche
anno fa ho girato un film documentario
che si intitola gesù è morto per i
peccati degli altri
a catania in un quartiere che tutti
conosciamo
a catania san berillo questo quartiere
che si trova al centro di catania
difficilmente viene attraversato le
persone quando devono andare da una
parte all'altra ci girano intorno non lo
attraversano perché sanno anche se non
ci sono mai state che il quartiere delle
prostitute degli immigrati dei senza
tetto né legge dei palazzi decadenti di
qualcosa che sta ai margini
di ciò che decoroso anche io
date queste premesse non c'ero mai
entrata finché non ci sono capitata per
caso
spero sulle tracce della scrittrice
goliarda sapienza catanese d'origine che
visse a catania i primi quindici anni
della sua vita e nacque a catania alla
fine degli anni venti poi dopo quindi il
quindicesimo anno andò a roma di vento
attrice e rimase poi a roma
per il resto della sua vita questa
scrittrice ha scritto un libro molto
importante che si intitola l'arte della
gioia anche un bellissimo titolo e
questo libro tormentò la scrittrice
perché lei invitano riuscì mai a
pubblicarlo
quindi un libro per noi invisibile morta
la scrittrice fu pubblicato in una
piccola casa editrice in poche copie che
quindi insomma arrivarono a chi proprio
ci riuscì a leggerle però arrivarono in
francia e la francia pubblico invece una
buona casa editrice pubblico questo
libro l'arte della gioia lo tradusse lo
pubblicò e ebbe un successo strepitoso e
da lì passoni alla germania in spagna è
finalmente in italia un grosso editore
più di dieci anni dopo la morte della
scrittrice lo pubblicò e io lasci
quell'edizione
sto parlando di circa 10 anni fa e mi
innamorai così tanto di questo libro che
pensai
com'è possibile che a catania la si
conosca così poco io da catanese no e
allora decisi di andare a cercare la
casa dove vogliamo aveva trascorso i
suoi primi 15 anni la bambina filippi
c'erano delle tracce di questa dove si
potesse trovare e queste tracce
portavano proprio a san berillo e alla
parte di san berillo che ancora esiste
perché sappiamo che san berillo in
passato era un quartiere molto più ampio
e allora andai nel quartiere e scoprire
a casa di goliarda che emozione e che
sorpresa
l'attuale proprietario della casa di
goliarda non sapevo assolutamente nulla
di volerla sapienza del suo libro e
addirittura questo nome goliarda
sapienza
lo fece un po ridere però
con molta attenzione il mio invece
racconto entusiasmante ma alla fine mi
disse se volevo fare un giro giu nel
quartiere
egli accetta e che emozione che sorpresa
la seconda una giornata proprio da
cardiopalma e ri emersi dall'incontro
col quartiere in prima persona e delle
strade dei palazzi ed al dialogo con le
persone con una voglia di volerne sapere
di più un desiderio di volerne sapere di
avere una voglia di conoscere meglio e
quindi indomani scesi nel quartiere di
tall sugli occhiali imbracciare la mia
telecamera e trascorsi del tempo li
nell'intenzione di fare un film
ho trascorso tre anni prima di girare
con la troupe da sola con la mia
telecamera prendere appunti perché mi
serve per capire quello che voglio
girare o quello che mi arriva e in
questi tre anni sin dall'inizio dissi
subito la mia intenzione era di girare
un film lo sapevano tutti
però c'è chi rideva sì mi prenderà in
giro kimi cacciava e poi però trascorsi
anche del bel tempo insieme alle donne e
alle prostitute davanti alle porte
chiuse o davanti le porte aperte o a
prendere un caffè a sentire i loro
racconti a osservare e loro mi
guardavano con sospetto perché avevo una
telecamera era una donna ed ero sola
però un po confuse mostravano sinistra
bordanti gambe nude e tutto quel
visibile che pensavano vi bastasse
perché io me ne andassi e io invece
restavo perché non era quello che mi
sembrava potesse essere la forma del
racconto che volevo fare
e man mano che rimanevo invece che
ottenere delle risposte
le mie domande aumentavano era come se
cominciassi concentrici laddove si sia
tirato un sasso è uno specchio d'acqua
queste domande proprio aumentavano
aumentavano e allargavano
zona dove era caduto il sasso cioè la
mia prima domanda è questo manifestava
più aspetti della realtà cioè come se la
realtà particolare che stava osservando
allargandosi con tutte queste domande in
qualche modo manifestati qualcosa della
realtà più ampia e così mi lasciai
invadere da queste domande è
un'esperienza sconcertante entrare in
contatto con ciò che è diverso da noi
con ciò che non conosciamo e sta ai
margini ai bordi della nostra visione
che ci espone al di fuori delle nostre
sicurezze ed è per questo che importiamo
gli occhiali per non rivoluzionare i
nostri punti fermi
abbiamo studiato anche a scuola la
conoscenza si evolve non solo attraverso
l'accumulo del sapere ma attraverso
visioni e rivoluzioni
tutti abbiamo studiato a scuola la
rivoluzione copernicana copernico pone
al centro del sistema solare il sole sta
usando completamente la precedente
concezione geocentrica in cui è la terra
al centro di tutto ma pensiamo a galileo
galilei inventore del metodo
sperimentale processato come
rivoluzionario accusato di eresia
costretto a rinnegare le sue teorie e
messo agli arresti domiciliari
galileo galilei grandi menti queste che
hanno rivoluzionato il nostro modo di
pensare dando corpo all'invisibile al
impensato oppure pensiamo a o lampade
guscio non conoscete questo nome non
potete pensarla perché è stata
completamente cancellata dalla storia
non l'abbiamo studiata quando si
studiavamo la rivoluzione francese
eppure o lampade guscio nel 1791 strisce
la dichiarazione della donna e della
cittadina in risposta alla dichiarazione
dell'uomo e del cittadino che tutti
conosciamo partorita dalla rivoluzione
francese
al grido di libertè fraternitè e
legalità o più o meno al contrario la
stessa cosa
questa donna lo script strisce questa
dichiarazione perché non si sentiva
incluso in quella dichiarazione si
sentiva invisibile di questa cosa ha
mobilitato le domande e queste domande
non solo come donna ma anche come
cittadina sono domande come questa cosa
sarebbe successo alla mia vita non solo
come donna ma anche come cittadina e
alla vostra vita di cittadini e
cittadine
se avessimo avuto l'opportunità di
studiare sui libri di scuola
l'esistenza di questa dichiarazione
scritta dall ampio del guscio dove ci
proponevano pari diritti tra uomini e
donne e pari opportunità 1791 diamo
corpo all'invisibile
quando ci apriamo all'ascolto di quello
che non conosciamo
quando ci apriamo una nuova possibilità
io lo faccio con i miei film quello che
ho detto prima
cerco di costruire visioni contagiose
comune come una risata e come faccio
questa significa ricostruire visioni
contagiose in qualche modo io
ricostruisco la mia domanda iniziale e
cerco di non dimenticare e di mantenere
tutte le domande che sono venute via via
attraverso l'osservazione della realtà
sulla quale mi sono calata per cui in
qualche modo voglio restituire il mio
desiderio più grande è restituire la mia
esperienza diretta di quella realtà è
che dico cosa è fatta questa esperienza
tre anni prima di girare questa
esperienza è fatta di tempo è un tempo
però particolare un po un perdere tempo
e vi piace chiamare tempo del pensiero
non è il tempo che scandisce le nostre
giornate
negli impegni quotidiani eh sì cosa
acquisto di particolare questo tempo del
pensiero è come se il tempo si dirà
trash su come pensare una cosa
nell'ora e mezza di film che contagio in
tecnico contagiare lo spettatore mi
piace pensare che lo spettatore sia
messo nelle condizioni di pensare
attraverso questa visione e di avere una
propria libertà per la riflessione
questo perché io nei miei film non do
giudizi ma sto molto attenta ci vuole
una grande disciplina senza occhiali
eccetera per poter mantenere le domande
vive aperte su quella realtà sconosciuta
due anni fa
due anni dopo l'uscita del mio film mi
sono trovata di nuovo a san berillo in
qualche modo non me ne sono mai andata
d'acqua schiera perché sono entrato a
far parte della nascente associazione
trame di quartiere c'è un'associazione
che ha sede a san berillo
un'associazione sulla rigenerazione
urbana e che ha sede proprio in uno dei
palazzi storici di san berillo uno di
quelli che stavano pescando e che invece
piano piano siamo riusciti a rendere
vivibile e sempre con progetti sempre
più ampie
all'interno di questa associazione io
avevo il compito di immaginare un
laboratorio per un documentario
documentario diciamo si chiama
laboratorio di produzione
documentaristica e per immaginarlo il
mio desiderio più grande era che si
mobilitassero altre visioni oltre la mia
e che si moltiplicassero le visioni su
quartiere in modo da restituirne la
complessità e così i venti iscritti e
laboratorio per la prima annualità poi
ce ne furono 20 per la seconda annualità
incamminarono in questo percorso per la
realizzazione di una web serie
documentaristica quindi tanti episodi e
quindi l'opportunità di raccontare più
aspetti di questa realtà è il primo
atteggiamento e io è qui nei confronti
di questi giovani che venivano comunque
da esperienze differenti quindi
interessante avevano occhiali tutti
diversi non c'era chi veniva da economia
chi veniva da dall'antropologia dal
flusso logie era uno studente videomaker
quindi tutti ognuno aveva i suoi piccoli
occhialetti il mio primo diciamo dare è
stato focalizzato su non sull'estetica
dell'immagine e quindi sulle regole
della fotografia e della ripresa no per
pura comunque dovevo trasmettere ma
sull'osservazione del campo perché credo
che l'educazione all'immagine
innanzitutto educazione allo sguardo
cioè capacità di osservazione che non è
una cosa così scontata
e allora questi 20 e poi 20 quindi 40
studenti hanno realizzato una web serie
documentaristica di tanti episodi dove
hanno restituito la loro visione sono
stati incoraggiati all'interno del
laboratorio da me stessa a andare a
conversare a perdere tempo con la gente
a sentire dialogo i discorsi anche
magari a uscire dal quartiere andare
dall assessore non farlo parlare del
quartiere insomma per farci una loro
visione pensando attraverso le loro
domande
e così oggi per tutti visibile in rete
la serie si titola san berillo web serie
doc
e quando ci facciamo contagiare da
qualcosa che non conosciamo da qualcosa
che è lontano da noi e non vediamo
oppure che è vicinissimo a noi ma non lo
vediamo lo stesso perché è invisibile
invisibili dato in pensato ecco quando
ci facciamo contagiare da qualcosa
questo qualcosa che è diverso non
sfuggiamo al pensiero astratto e apriamo
uno spazio e un tempo per il pensiero
concreto è una pratica artigianale sul
come guardare una cosa e sul come
poterla esplorare e quindi costruiamo
delle visioni e diamo corpo
all'invisibile
i meccanismi di invisibilità zione di
esclusione individuali collettivi
impliciti espliciti legali o illegali
emergono solo quando non li diamo come
un dato di fatto e quindi si può avere
una telecamera essere una regista come
me oppure un aspirante videomaker ma
tutti possiamo farlo con o senza
telecamera possiamo andare a vedere come
stanno le cose
osservare alla realtà lasciarsi
attraversare dalle nostre domande per
liberare la nostra capacità di visione e
conoscere liberamente la strada è più
lunga ma faremo strada
[Applauso]
[Musica]